Currently there are 118 elements that we have
discovered and logged on the Periodic table.
Elements are strange things, simply adding
or removing a single proton from the atom's
nucleus of an element completely changes it
and essentially makes it a new element.
Here's the weirdest elements from the periodic
table, that seem to defy the laws of physics.
1.
First up, Gallium is a soft metal that's sometimes
used in electronics.
But it has a unique party trick, it safely
melts in human hands, then resolidifies again
once it drops below its 30 Celsius melting
point.
In the early 20th century a popular prank
amongst chemists at university was to smelt
gallium into utensils then watch as their
classmate's knife and fork melted away from
their hands as they ate.
2.
But if you think a metal becoming a liquid
at room temperature is weird, how about a
metal being a gas at room temperature.
Copernicium is a highly radioactive synthetic
metal.
It is one of the weirdest and most elusive
elements, because of two reasons.
Firstly it decays extremely fast, it has an
astonishingly short half-life of just 29 seconds,
so it doesn't stick around for very long.
And secondly it is a gas at room temperature.
Both these factors make it extremely difficult
for scientists to study, subsequently we still
don't know very much about this elusive substance.
3.
Curium is an extremely radioactive substance
that was named after Marie Curie.
Only a few kilograms of curium are produced
each year because it doesn't have very many
uses.
However it was used on a Mars mission in an
Alpha Proton X-Ray Spectrometer.
But what makes this element so unique is that
it's so radioactive, it actually glows in
the dark.
4.
Next up is Francium, a naturally occurring
element named after France, Francium is one
of the alkali metals, all of which are extremely
volatile.
But Francium is the most reactive of all the
alkali metals.
At it's most stable isotope it has a very
short half-life of 22 minutes and is unbelievably
rare, it usually pops into existence one atom
at a time then disappears almost instantaneously.
It is estimated that there are only about
20 grams of Francium on the planet at any
one time.
Scientists aren't even able to procure a sample
of Francium large enough so it's visible to
the naked eye, therefore studying it is almost
impossible.
But we know that when put into water the reaction
would be spectacularly dangerous.
Considering that the next most reactive alkali
metal is Cesium, which explodes when it touches
water.
However Francium is considerably more volatile
than Cesium and just the moisture in the air
alone would cause Francium to explode spectacularly.
5.
Next up is a group of 8 different elements,
all relatively new to the periodic table.
They are all manmade, they all have similar
names (Ununbium, Ununtrium, Ununquadium, Ununpentium,
Ununhexium, Ununseptium, Ununoxium) and were
all discovered in the exact same manner.
By scientists bombarding atoms of one element
with atoms of another element.
This separates them into a completely new
element, but for only a fraction of a second.
The first to be discovered, Ununbium was first
created in 1996 in a lab in Germany.
None of these elements have been seen for
more than a second and their inclusion on
the periodic table still remains under investigation.
6.
Bismuth is the heaviest non radioactive metal.
Actually it is very very slightly radioactive,
but it has a half life billions of times longer
than the current age of the universe, so for
arguments sake, it's fair to say that it's
completely stable.
Bismuth is used in medicine and cosmetics.
But it has a unique attribute, it is diamagnetic.
Which means it emits a magnetic field in the
opposite direction to any externally applied
magnetic field.
In layman's terms, if you put a magnet between
two lumps of bismuth it will levitate indefinitely.
7.
You probably imagine sulphur as a yellow rock,
but it can actually change to an array of
different colours in different conditions.
One of the weirdest such example can be seen
if you melt sulphur, it turns from a solid
yellow rock to a blood-red liquid.
Also just as cool, if you burn sulphur, it
produces a neon blue flame.
But sulphur has a disgusting side, it's responsible
for the odour of rotten eggs, garlic, onions
and many other nasty smells.
In fact most things that smell bad have some
sulphur in there somewhere.
8.
Next up is Helium, it's a colourless, odourless,
tasteless, inert gas, which means it doesn't
react with other elements.
Its boiling and melting points are the lowest
of any element.
At an unimaginably low -272.2 degrees Celsius,
Helium turns into a superfluid.
Which exhibits a unique property, if you pour
helium in its superfluid form into a vessel
it seems to defy gravity and creep up the
walls of the container and pour over the rim
to try and reach a warmer place, where it
will eventually evaporate.
But by far the thing that makes Helium so
damn extraordinary is this.
9.
If it wasn't for this next element, you wouldn't
be watching this video right now.
I am of course talking about silicon, a crucial
component in all computer chips and most electronics.
It's even got an entire valley named after
it in California.
It's also responsible for silky white beaches,
being the most common component in sand.
Oh and don't forget breast implants.
It's one of the most common elements on earth,
about 27 percent of the earth's crust is made
up of silicon.
Silicon is a remarkable element because it's
largely responsible for the technological
revolution of the past 30 years.
10.
And finally, it may not be particularly strange,
but it is arguably the coolest element.
The element I'm talking about is Carbon.
It is the most essential element to support
life.
It is the building block of everything living.
DNA, proteins, cells, coal, pencils, diamonds,
the air you breath and the food you eat are
all made up from carbon, as well as countless
other things.
Carbon compromises 20% of the weight of all
living organisms.
To put it simply, if it wasn't for carbon
we wouldn't be here, and neither would the
universe as we know it, so for that reason
alone it deserves some attention.